okay i'll play m sog
wow we're returning to normal chess now
this feels weird
so we'll see if
i'm like i'm more creative now
having just played chess 960
let's play b3 i'll try and play
creatively
oh i think black's playing the shanzi
wall
yeah black's playing the shanzi wall oh
that's so funny
i don't know what i'm doing
uh
i guess i'll play this move
it's probably not a great move
okay let's let's attack the wall
this is probably like a really bad
opening from both of us
yeah the shanzi wall is this this
and this
i don't think black is ready for this
uh if you have amazon prime you can use
uh
i think the prime command
it'll give you further instructions
okay i'll play 92
maybe knight c3
envisioning the knight coming to f4
someday
wow
as bishop is really misplaced
also i meant to play queen g3 there i
play queen h3
okay
i'm pretty sure like after
i moved four it was probably a
completely new position
yeah sadly this bishop is going to have
to
be sad on d3
yes generally when i do viewer
challenges there's a lot of people that
want to play so
the best strategy is to challenge and be
patient
um
if you're a sub you can make your name
purple using the
me chest command
have i seen any good movies recently
um
oh i'm about to see a good movie
there's a viewer that sent me
blu-ray of the
gladiator which uh arrived yesterday
it was part of my homework to watch the
gladiator now i just need to find a
blu-ray player
and uh
yeah i feel like it's a classic movie
that i just haven't seen before so
[Music]
i can't even remember the last movie i
saw
play king b1
it's possible this uh there's probably a
code for like a digital
download
oh
[Music]
wait i'm in trouble here
if i play this there's queen b5
oh no
i don't want to lose to the shanzi wall
but i have a i have a rosen wall
not entirely sure what my wall is doing
though
expand the wall
i'll play knight h1
kind of a random move but i want to move
the knight here i also want to have some
tricks against the bishop
oh i missed queen f1
i did i could have played king c2 queen
f1
but
i'm also okay gambiting the pawn
this move
rook c4
thank you anura g posse
the prime sub
okay so the goal
is to win this pawn
um because this pawn is pinned
okay four
not so easy though
by d3
i really want to play this but it loves
this
yeah my rook's gonna be uh
it's kind of living on the edge
it's undefended it has really no great
squares to go to
a3 is still a possibility
expecting this in this
but after queen c6 i have b4
[Music]
the queen here
[Music]
the g5
knight doesn't really have any moves
it's tied down to defending the bishop
a g6
i'm ready to play b4
wow
so the king defends the bishop
now the knight's just chilling in the
corner
i have less than 10 seconds
i guess i'll play this
such an ugly position
i'm still fighting
go for this in 94
idea 96 now
yeah there's still hope
maybe take this next
q move
like i'm down the exchange
but the
knight's stuck in the corner
d4 is coming too
okay the rosen wall is expanding
and the shanzi wall is
cracking
although that's still a fight
i take this thing
i could
okay these pawns are gonna hopefully
save me
they better save me
does that move
all my pawns are defended actually
there's a scheme
oh no my knight
hey i have three pawns
a rosen wall what is this
jack
check
check
oh that was so satisfying
that was so satisfying
what a game
oh
yeah don't mess with the rosenwald
it's like a really
that wasn't even a wall that was like a
ceiling
a really high ceiling like a loft
if this were three check yeah this would
have been a
really dramatic ending to three check
it's not every day like a queen appears
and vanishes
so many times
okay hello to youtube
i feel like the start of that game was
just pure meaning
but uh
yeah for those that are unfamiliar with
the shanzi wall
[Music]
um the shanzi ball is a setup that
involves this this
this is this or wait no this this
and then
it's
very wall-like